site I mean Ibrahim off doesn't come
alone to the river hill near Strasbourg
to fish anymore last August two men
attacked him here and it's a miracle
that he lived to tell the story go there
prefer sadocha nearly hit me on the head
from behind their lizard you forgot yeah
then they dragged me into the woods and
tortured me there with a close eye on
the chest the back everywhere which room
no rudeness pianist yeah Ibrahim offered
hope to be able to live in freedom when
he sought refuge in Strasbourg 12 years
ago he had flown from the violence and
torture of the Russians in Chechnya but
Moscow's long arm caught up with him in
the West Ibrahim off is convinced that
the torturers were henchmen of Russian
President Putin for a long time he had
been receiving threats that something
would happen if he didn't withdraw his
suit against Putin heard this more my
letter to the International Court of
Justice in The Hague anyway would you
know in it i accused Putin of having
committed crimes against the Chechen
people in the 1990s Ibrahim off was
communications minister and a legal
expert in Chechnya autonomous government
he's assembled a huge dossier alleging
Putin's responsibility for kidnappings
and murders committed by the Russian
army in Chechnya
you break him off once justice with
legal means he's a pacifist and he's
always rejected Chechen violence and
they're striving for independence yeah
I'm against any holy war or terrorism I
oppose all violence or bloodshed all
wall Ibrahim off had placed his hopes in
the European Council he provided pages
and pages of reports on atrocities in
Chechnya and is bitterly disappointed
that he never received an answer the
council's headquarters in Strasbourg
knows of Ibrahim auvs case but doesn't
want to comment on it personally I think
that the council of europe is
fundamentally parliamentary assemblies
from dimensionally about dialogue it's
not a military organization and I think
that it's best to continue that dialogue
with the Russian authorities and the
Russian delegation Ibrahim off is one of
30,000 Chechens who fled from their
country to France they all live in fear
of reprisals duel each each angular hope
so repertory the Russian Secret Service
has registered all the Chechens in
Europe and Russia's governor in Chechnya
Hadiya of systematically sends agents to
threaten them and get the exiles to
return to Chechnya if the threats don't
work they resort to physical attacks
Yossi desecration this intimidation
works hardly any victims of attacks file
charges against the perpetrators the
French judiciary seems to turn a blind
eye representatives of Chechens abroad
even speak of massive French Russian
cooperation buddies false a secure the
French Secret Service receives
information about Chechen terrorists
from the Russian Secret Service set up
in return the French provide all kinds
of information on peaceable Chechens who
have applied for asylum here
although these Mokpo and that's not loud
yell quantity information a cause de
vous nah man whoa satin teddy ibrahim oz
last hope is the International Court in
The Hague every day he hopes to hear
that his case will be heard for Nick
aggressive anyway if the international
community doesn't condemn Putin he'll
continue committing crimes he will never
admit his guilt nor we wish to read most
attacks on Putin critics in exile have
something in common the perpetrators
remain at large Ibrahim of has survived
six attacks so far but every day he has
to fear the next one